Justin Bieber oh geez played an April
Fool's prank on all of us all and some
aren't laughing so Justin started with
this photo of a sonogram no caption just
posted that photo on Instagram I'll tell
you now though people didn't know at the
time but Justin pulled this photo from
the Wikipedia page for ultrasounds yeah
but seeing that photo people like Ellen
DeGeneres and Kris Jenner was skeptical
but very excited Justin's wife Haley
commented saying very funny so that made
many people think it was in fact an
April Fool's yes
well Justin wasn't done there no an hour
later he posted this photo of Haley in
wrote if you thought it was April Fool's
that really had everyone freaking out of
this she's getting a tattoo and I think
yeah we don't know what that photo is
because Justin had said it wasn't a joke
yeah well shortly after Justin posted on
Instagram wait oMG is that uh April
Fool's and yes that's the puppy now
appearing in the ultrasound or on the
ultrasound some slam Justin making the
point that so many women struggle to get
pregnant can't get pregnant or lose
babies during pregnancy yes that's all
you go first well here's my thing I did
that once with on April everything was
April Fool's with my husband I showed
our original pregnancy pee stick thing
and I did get some people being angry
about it but I mean I think the thing is
you're not you're not discounting the
hurt and the pain that other people have
with infertility you're talking about
are you going to expand your family yes
or no so it's like saying if I celebrate
my job am I saying that I'm not happier
I'm I feel less for people who are
unemployed like not to equate the two
but there's there's no hurt in this this
was a joke
people speculate every day if women on
television are pregnant or in the public
eye every time I had a burger people
thought it was pregnant and so I think
they were having fun with all the eyes
that are constantly on them trying to do
something harmless and I just we live in
such a society where people are so angry
and want to take people down that I just
find it like really that's no people
support people who have infertility
problems and who lose children that's
incredibly serious
but let's not rip people down because
you want to make yourself feel but it
just to me does
makes sense like given if you made a
joke about miscarriages
that's so funny if that was part of like
he just said that they were pregnant and
then they were pregnant oh yeah of
course is people that start with things
via almost every joke that you make you
can make a case for it all joke or short
jokes but yeah absolutely infertility is
a huge issue piss don't think there's
anything wrong I have with this if
you're like an April Fool's joke yes you
have to do it once cuz then he like he
doubled down right cuz then he posted
the second photo see now just fine and
now you're just being that guy I mean
but I mean it feel like a joke here he
gets deal once cuz any double down says
no no this is an April Fool's joke yeah
you shouldn't any there's a world yeah
one what's time to tell that joke joy
says people have lost their sense of
humor own April Fool's somebody else's
they didn't find that an April Fool's
joke funny at all
joy says it's just this joke Mikey
person thought it was hilarious Lou says
so she stuffed a pillow under her
clothes without a bit more sensitive
it's just a joke yeah yeah and it
doesn't take away again from people who
are hurting that's a very real thing but
this is not this is it like the idea of
like would it be then if you know you're
talking about your kids how you love
being a mom is that insensitive exactly
exactly at a certain point you can take
offense to almost anything I suppose and
we support all those who are hurting for
sure and Justin is now apologized on
Instagram saying there's always gonna be
people offended there's always people
who don't take jokes very well I'm a
prankster and it was April Fool's I
didn't at all mean to be insensitive to
people who can't have children a lot of
people I know their first go to prank on
April Fool's is telling their parents
they're pregnant to get a big reaction
but I will apologize anyway and take
responsibility and say story to people
who were offended I truly don't want
anyone to be hurt by a prank some might
have laughed but some were offended I
think what pranks you sometimes have to
roll that dice